now that we know a little bit about
oxidation and reduction what I want to
do is think is is really just do an
exercise to just make sure that we can
at least give our best shot at figuring
out the oxidation states for the
constituent atoms inside of a core that
make up a compound so for example here I
have magnesium oxide which is used in
cement and as other applications and
this is magnesium hydroxide which is
actually used in in antacids it's used
in deodorant and what I want you to
think about and I encourage you to pause
this video right now is given these two
molecules these two compounds and what
we know about the periodic table try to
come up with the oxidation states for
the different elements in each of these
compounds so I'm assuming you've given a
go at it now let's try to work through
this or think through this together so
first of all magnesium magnesium right
over here we see its group - it's an
alkaline earth metal it has two valence
electrons it's not that electronegative
we've already seen that something in
this group right over here with two
valence electrons it's likely to give
them away so if it were to form ionic
bonds or if it were to be ionized it's
likely to lose two electrons if you lose
two electrons you would have a plus two
charge so magnesium would typically have
a plus two oxidation state on the other
side of the periodic table oxygen group
seven it has six valence electrons it's
very electronegative so electronegative
that oxidation is named for it it likes
to take electrons from other elements
and an oxygen particular likes to take
two electrons so it's not unusual to see
actually anything in this group but
especially oxygen taking two electrons
from something else if you take two
electrons and you started off neutrally
or you started in a neutral state it's
not unusual to see oxygen at a negative
two oxidation state so given that it
seems like this could work out magnesium
could have a positive to positive two
oxidation state and actually when you
write it as a superscript here the
convention is to write the positive
after
the to and oxygen would have or could
have a negative two oxidation state and
this makes sense relative to the overall
charge of the molecule positive two plus
negative two is going to be zero and
that makes sense this thing overall is a
neutral molecule and not only in this
case is the oxidation state a
hypothetical ionic charge if these were
to be ionic bonds this actually is an
ionic compound oxygen actually does take
two electrons and magnesium actually
does give away two electrons so in this
case the oxidation state is actually
describing what is happening ionic Li
now let's think about this one right
over here magnesium hydroxide well just
like before magnesium typically has an
oxidation state likes to give away its
electrons so it could have an oxidation
state of positive two oxidation state of
positive 2 which it imply that the
entire hydroxide anion and let's think
about or let's just say hydroxide for
now well I'll say hydroxide anion I kind
of gave it away a little bit that this
hydroxide that or this part of the
molecule the right-hand part of what
I've written here should for this whole
thing to be neutral it should have a
negative two oxidation state
now how does that make sense well we
have two we have two hydroxides here
notice the subscript right over here so
if each of those hydroxides has a
negative one negative one charge or a
negative one I guess you could say total
oxidation state then we use some when
you take the two of them together they
would net out against the magnesium and
that does seem to make sense if oxygen
has a negative two oxidation state
hydrogen has a positive 1 oxidation
state each each hydroxide part of this
molecule is going to have a net
oxidation state of negative one but then
you have two of them so the net
oxidation for this part of the molecule
or the compound is going to be negative
two Nets out with a positive two from
magnesium so once again it makes sense